[Musique]
on est aujourd'hui le dimanche 25
décembre c'est le genre noël je voulais
vous souhaite à tous un excellent noël
j'espère que vous allez bonne fait que
vous avez passé de bonnes fêtes que vous
avez la panse bien remplie et que
vraiment vous avez passé un noël
extraordinaire et que vous avez été gâté
et couverts de cadeaux
j'espère que oui en tout cas ici c'est
vraiment sympa on a passé un moment qui
est vraiment pape alors je sais quand
vous verrez cette vidéo on sera déjà le
lundi 26 décembre l'événement sera pas
scellé par contre là on est en plein
dedans tout de suite mais c'est vraiment
un moment qui est exceptionnel voilà je
voulais partager avec vous aujourd'hui
une vidéo qui est un peu plus courte
forcément vous vous en douterez il faut
aller festoyer il ya tout le monde qui à
côté tout le monde m'attend donc je vais
rapidement y retourner je voulais faire
un petit débrief là on est déjà à la 11è
vidéo tournait tout de suite il ya eu
dix vidéos de blogs
je voulais déjà pour remercier
énormément pour tous les partages toutes
les réactions tous les live sur facebook
sur twitter sur youtube ça me fait
vraiment énormément plaisir alors c'est
un début pour l'instant y'a pas encore
énormément de monde
si vous voulez rajouter un petit cadeau
de noël pour moi trouve sapin vous
pouvez venir vous abonner venir partager
venir visionner ça c'est vraiment
extraordinaire
un grand merci à vous on s'est vraiment
fait plaisir cette semaine on a déjà été
voir un énorme clubs de top 14 de rugby
c'était une journée magnifique une star
de la chanson qu'on a été visité et qui
nous a fait à manger c'était
exceptionnel merci beaucoup
on est aussi faire un tour tout et des
locaux de radio scoop dont vraiment quoi
ressemble à une station de radio
exceptionnel plein de choses qui ont été
partagés plein de choses qui ont été
faites
je suis persuadé que ça va continuer
comme ça qu'il va y avoir plein de
sujets plein de vidéos plein de choses
sympas j'espère pouvoir vous rencontrer
dans la rue si on se croise on se fait
un bisou en soi un câlin et qui ont ce
film ce sera un super moment des changes
je vous remercie en tout cas d'avoir
visionné merci beaucoup merci encore
merci infiniment
joyeux noël passer de bonnes fêtes
réveillonner bien soyez heureux et puis
nous on se revoit dès demain le lundi
je vais tourner la prochaine vidéo le
lundi 26 décembre et vous pourrez
visionner le mardi 27 au matin
bisous alléger enfin bisous et pour toi
pour toi spécialement
ouf
[Musique]